es sind wirklich dramatische nachrichten
die uns heute morgen aus rheinland-pfalz
erreicht haben zwei polizisten eine 24
jährige und ein 29-jähriger sind dort
kaltblütig erschossen worden die zwei
beamten kontrollierten gegen 24
routinemäßig ein fahrzeug im kofferraum
entdeckten die beiden totes wild und
wollten dann die personalien der
fahrzeugführer aufnehmen ja dann kam es
plötzlich zu den tödlichen schüssen der
oder die täter sind noch auf der flucht
kurz zuvor da konnten die beiden beamten
noch funksprüche absetzen zuerst
berichten sie eben von dem toten wird im
kofferraum kurz darauf kommt dann
plötzlich der zweite hektische
funkspruch die schießen auf uns danach
reist der kontakt mit den polizisten
kollegen finden die beiden tot neben
ihrem fahrzeug und weil es hieß die
schießen auf uns gehen die ermittler
derzeit von mindestens zwei tätern aus
möglicherweise wilderer die waffen dabei
haben und so geschaltet ist jetzt bild
chefreporter frank schneider fragen das
sind wirklich dramatische nachrichten
die uns da aus rheinland pfalz erreichen
hast du irgendwelche neuen informationen
für uns
naja die fahndung läuft jetzt auf
hochtouren das ist das einzige was die
polizei momentan machen kann man will
natürlich jetzt erstmal dieser möglichen
2 oder auch noch mehr tatverdächtigen
habhaft werden die polizei warnt die
bevölkerung auch im momentan keine
anhalter mitzunehmen keine verdächtigen
person möglicherweise aufzunehmen es
könnte ja auch sein sie sind zwar erst
mal mit einem fahrzeug geflüchtet was er
das fahrzeug abgestellt haben dass sie
zu fuß auf der flucht sind
möglicherweise sind sie aber auch schon
in einem anderen bundesland sehr weit
weg das kann die polizei momentan nicht
sagen aber die ermittlungen laufen auf
hochtouren das problem ist es war um 420
eine uhrzeit wenn kaum ein mensch auf
der straße ist und eben abgelegen in
einem waldstück das heißt es gibt
überhaupt keine tatzeugen es gibt keine
beobachtung mit was für einem
tatfahrzeug sie geflüchtet sind und die
beamten haben wohl nichts mehr mitteilen
können
franke sind solche vorfälle einzelfälle
oder kann man da eine entwicklung
erkennen dass das immer mehr werden
ja also es geht immer mal ein jahr auf
einem jahr unter also es gibt immer
wieder diese schusswaffen gebräuche so
nennt die polizei dass im juristischen
deutsch
gegen tatverdächtige die gewalt
gegenüber polizeibeamten natürlich schon
zugenommen aber zum glück sind solche
fälle wie der jetzt in der vergangenen
nacht doch eher noch die einzelfälle
insbesonders auf polizisten so
kaltblütig geschossen wird aber es gibt
sie leider immer wieder werden immer
wieder fälle gehabt wir haben so einen
ähnlichen fall gehabt auch schon vor 30
jahren da haben zwei brüder allerdings
gezielt in einem waldstück polizisten
hin gelockt haben von einem wildunfall
erzählt man muss ja auch hier sagen es
soll totes wild jedenfalls nach angaben
der beiden beamten als sie noch mit der
leitstelle kontakt aufnehmen konnten
wild gefunden worden seien es kann ja
auch theoretisch sein dass die beiden
einen unfall hatten die tatverdächtigen
mit einem wildschwein oder ähnlichen das
ist gar nicht geschossen haben sondern
es ist deshalb vielleicht im kofferraum
lag das wissen jetzt um den zeitpunkt
noch nicht damals war es so man hat
einen wildunfall vorgetäuscht hat die
beiden beamten jetzt waldstück gelockt
und hat sie dann motiv hass auf
polizisten erschossen da wir
mittlerweile wissen wie viel hast immer
auf polizei auch herrscht und die
polizei immer als ersatzgegner für
diesen verhassten staat gesehen wird
muss man natürlich auch immer befürchten
und das tut auch die polizei dass es
auch ein politisches motiv geben könnte
auch bei solch einer tat das weiß
momentan noch keiner die polizei mittelt
natürlich wie es immer heißt in alle
richtungen das heißt es könnte sein es
kommt bei der kontrolle dazu dass die
beamten merken einer dieser männer oder
beide männer werden gesucht dann
eskaliert dass es kann sein dass die
männer etwas zu verbergen haben was die
waren im auto entdecken vielleicht auch
die waffen und dann kann es immer noch
sein dass es gezielt ist dass es ein
angriff auf polizisten ist der geplant
ist und das muss die polizei jetzt
klären und wie gesagt dieser täter
schnell habhaft werden zwei polizisten
so eiskalt tötet wird ja auch weiter
nicht davor zurückschrecken auf andere
menschen zu schießen frank dankeschön
für diese ganz aktuellen infos du
bleibst natürlich dran an diesem fall
sobald der neue entwicklungen gibt es
einfach wieder bei dir